hello everyone and welcome back to the
semi-finals of the magnus carlson
invitational this is the other match on
ishgiri versus
wesley so and this is already the fourth
game the first three games ended in a
draw which definitely
is not going in wesley's favor as geary
won the first day and now uh wesley
needs a win in the final game to bounce
back into the fourth tie break so let's
see what happened
uh giri with the white pieces here and
he opens with
e4 we have e6 by wesley d4 and
d5 wesley goes for the french defense uh
and
e5 gary goes for the advanced variation
of the french we have c5 striking in the
center and c3 now
with a nice setup here in the center and
here uh the most common moves for black
are knight to c6 also queen to b6 is a
well-known move but here we have bishop
to d7 by wesley a less
a less known move not a less known move
but it's not played as often
and trying to throw geary off guard as
well geary's been making so many
uh so many uh videos uh and you know
master classes on openings that it's
hard for wesley to know uh the extent of
geary's knowledge
so here knight to f3 and knight to c6
now
not developing putting pressure on the
center we have bishop to e2 and
now knight g to e7 by wesley with the
idea of shifting the knight to f5 to put
even more pressure on the d4 pawn and
now knight the a3
this knight a3 looks uh looks weird but
if you try a normal move something like
knight to d2 then
you don't have sufficient defense of the
d4 pawn in black and
immediately try and take advantage of
this with captures captures and knight
f5 now
your d4 pawn will be attacked twice and
for example if knight b3
now you are defending it a5 trying to
get a4 in a4 and bishop to b for black
pretty much uh
sold all of his uh uh well opening
problems
so knight to a3 a bit different but it
works much better
and now if you try the same idea for
example captures and captures knight f5
doesn't do anything because this is
already
uh very well defended and the white can
just continue developing bring the
knight to the c2 and so on
so here instead after knight to a3 we
have knight to f5 by wesley
and now knight to c2 nicely
re-maneuvering the knight
over at the c2 now you have the knights
guarding the d4 square
and you can develop uh with bishop to d2
which would be impossible as the d4 pawn
would be undefended so here we have
cactus captures and bishop to e7
uh wesley preparing to castles uh we
have castles by geary and the castles by
wesley and now bishop to d2 now possible
as uh both of the knights are guarding
the the d4 pawn
we have rooked the c8 by wesley and now
there is a game where
uh bishop to c3 was played but here we
have bishop to d3 by giri and this is
now a new move in the position
b4 also possible uh for example a4b5 to
try and grab more space on the queen
side but
giri of course knows his stuff he goes
bishop to d3
and now at some point he will be able to
either capture or if the knight moves
that bishop will have very nice pressure
on the king's side
and of course it is as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so here uh
once white creates this sort of a setup
in the center black of course will
always most of the times try to
undermine it with
f6 and is this one of those uh well
cases where f6 simply uh doesn't work
uh we'll see uh gary grabs on f6 with
bishop captures on f6 and now bishop the
c3 now this is a very nice defender
also prevents black from pushing e5
which means that black will
remain for a very long time with the
backwards e6 pawn
that will be a weakness so here wesley
needs to figure out how to
now continue the game he can go queen to
b6 he can go queen to e8 followed by
queen to h5 there are a lot of
possibilities here maybe try and trade
over the night with
knight to h4 but he needs to continue
development so he starts with queen b6
connects the rooks
and now queen to d2 uh with queen b6
there's now
uh the this uh d4 pawn is now attacked
four times but uh
agiri doesn't need to defend it because
because of attack again i'm sure you
know what the tactic is without even me
uh saying it but for those of you who
are maybe new to chess
we will of course show it the problem is
if you started grabbing here for example
knight captures on the four knight
captures knight captures knight captures
uh and it does seem like you've taken
care of everything captures captures
captures captures
there's this captures in the end with
check and then
you're going to lose your queen captures
capture so you know a nice capture fest
in the center
but the white would now of course be
completely winning so wesley's next move
does not come as a surprise king h8
uh so at the end of this line bishop h7
would not come
with check so instead we have bishop
captures on f5
now geary eliminates one of the
attackers of the d4 pawn e captures and
now
knights the e5 an excellent square for
the knight
and if you uh if wesley decides to
capture it then the captures on e5 will
give
giri a nice past pawn so here bishop to
e6 the bishop is uh the bishop is under
attack so bishop to e6
and now uh geary trades knight
characters in c6
rook captures on c6 and rook f to e1
uh now putting pressure along the e file
we have bishop the g8 by wesley
and now comes rook to e2 geary just
prepares to double up on the e file
we have h6 a bit of a safety
safety move on the king side they're
also preparing bishop to g5 to put
pressure along this diagonal
rook 8 to e1 gary successfully doubles
up on the e
file and now bishop to g5 attacking
geary's queen with f4 pushing the bishop
back and bishop to f6
and now rook to e8 now gary offers a
trade of rooks and
tries to get some activity this way
so rook captures with rook captures and
now king to h7 wesley of course on pins
and now
queen to d3 putting pressure on the f5
pawn
and uh wesley defends it with bishop to
e6 also a very sneaky idea would have
been bishop to f7 kind of
forcing the rook to move and only then
protecting the pawn
because if you capture here with check
then bishop blocks and now you're going
to lose the rook after the queen moves
so okay after bishop to d3 bishop to e6
is also fine
uh and now g4 by erie taking advantage
of this as the
df5 pawn is pinned you will not be able
to capture it and now
what do you play here uh well the best
uh best move for wasting would be
something like queen to a6
uh you want to get the queen away from
this uh diagonal
uh so you're going to be able to capture
and queen the a6 does
exactly that now your white either
trades or gets the queen away from this
diagonal and then you can just
you know continue uh playing normally
and the black even should be better
however wesley misses a very crucial
idea here he plays queen to c7 puts
pressure on the f4 pawn
but this move now completely blunders
the game so feel free to pause the video
here and
win the game for anish while i give you
a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen while on b6 was guarding the
e6 square and now
uh as the queen shifted over to c7 that
is no longer happening because the queen
is not a knight
so here uh geary just played rook
captures on e6 so congratulations to
everyone who found that as
this is now a complete loss for black
and it was in this position on move 27
that wesley so resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
uh once the rook is captured there's
queen captures on f5 with check and you
lose the rook as well
while the queen was on b6 that would be
impossible but now of course it's not
soaking a cheat queen captures here and
yes you do get queen captures on f4 at
the end of all that but
uh there are no checks there are no
tricks there's nothing here
uh it's just a much better position for
for white you're up a piece
you don't really care about anything
here so of course wesley knows this
and uh after this uh rook captures on e6
he resigned and it's anish giri
versus yani pomachi in the finals of the
magnus carlsen invitational
uh which is pretty funny uh i i remember
in the first
video regarding this tournament i said
that the the
the favorites are definitely magnus
cross and yani ponishi and now both of
them were eliminated and now we have
geary versus
wesley so so uh we're gonna see we're
gonna see who who who takes it all
and it was uh this was a pretty pretty
crushing defeat i think uh because
wesley had some nine minutes on the
clock at the moment he blundered this
uh and he i mean objectively he did have
a better position
so uh tough break for wesley uh this was
a
this final game with the black beast was
a good way for him to get back into the
match and maybe force tie breaks but no
one is immune to blunders and
you know uh such as uh uh such was his
uh
faith uh in in in this game so first
three games in the draw gear he wins the
fourth one and
giri is now off to the finals to face uh
the russian that uh
eliminated magnus carlsen from the
competition and not just magnus also
hikaru
nippo eliminated magnus and hikaru so
giri definitely has his work cut out for
him
we're going to see i think some
excellent chess in the finals
uh so that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i would like to thank
fina got no hairline carlos alberto
zacosta
kevin hawkins richard moran and
alexander williamson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
the magnus crossing invitational
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and uh whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all uh uh i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
sunday